JAREK WILKIEWICZ:
This is how users
search the web on the desktop.
And this is how many users
search on mobile, OK, Google.
In fact, a recent study
shows that 55% of teens,
and 41% of adults, already use
Voice Search more than once
per day.
At Google we always
look for innovative ways
to help you improve
mobile search
and drive user engagement
back to your app.
Let's see a few examples.
When I'm ready to
plan a Hawaii trip
I can say, OK Google, search for
hotels in Maui on TripAdvisor.
That's right, the search took me
directly to the app on my phone
rather than the website.
To get in the vacation mood,
let's try ordering some pizza.
OK Google, search for
Hawaiian pizza on Eat24.
That's pretty yummy.
All I need now is
some Hawaiian tunes.
OK Google, search for
Hawaiian music on TuneIn.
As you can see,
TripAdvisor, Eat24, TuneIn,
and many other apps allow their
users to search using voice.
They have integrated
a feature called
Google Now actions
and so can you.
Google Now actions allow
you to take advantage
of Google's speech
recognition technology
to understand natural
language and turn it
into Android intents
delivered to your app.
In order to enable voice
search in your app,
declare an intent filter
in your AndroidManifest.xml
with a Google Now search action,
as shown in this example.
Once you make these
changes to your manifest,
you'll search activity, we'll
receive the search action
intent.
The intent will contain
a search manager
query extra with
the exact search
expression spoken by the user.
It's up to you to provide the
actual search implementation
in your app.
For example, using the on
device SQLite and FTS3.
A few simple changes to your
app will let your users search
using voice, using
Google Now actions.
For more information, check
out the link on the screen.